c'est là gérard vous avez obligé oui oui
quel est votre parce que vous aussi vous
êtes en train de vendre la v2 de vivre
la même chose
les coureurs automobiles s'engagent dans
des circonstances absolument terrible
dont il ne ressorte de temps en temps
pas alors est ce qu'ils disent par
exemple didier auriol qui est à côté de
vous didier hubert auriol didier villate
euralille michel c'est très simple moi
je parlais juste en tant que journaliste
des spécialistes de sport qu'est ce qui
fait courir ces gens là c'est tout
simplement le même plaisir que vous vous
avez par exemple tous les dimanches à
animer un débat police n'ont pas
toujours imposé c'est exactement la même
chose parce que tous ces grands
rédacteurs en chef là risquent leur vie
aussi toute la semaine avec leur plume
d'ange plaisante mais il ya une notion
de passion et je vais être un peu
manichéisme et où là la passion ou on ne
l'a pas et quand on l'a c'est vrai qu'on
peut mettre sa vie en question avec une
extrême facilité on n'a pas du tout
envie de la perdre
hubert va vous le confirmer il est
évident qu aucun des concurrents ici et
ici n'a envie de se blesser n'a envie de
la perdre mais ils ont envie d'aller au
bout de leur passion au bout de leur
rêve c'est un rêve de traverser
l'afrique avec une moto avec un camion
avec une voiture
c'est un rêve que de découvrir ces pays
c'est ce qu'on essaie de montrer
d'ailleurs sur france télévisions et il
essaie d'aller simplement des simplement
taxez vrai comme des grands gosses c'est
vrai il faut le dire aller au bout du
rêve